et on parle donc de ces négociations à
genève avec nicolas tenzer bonjour et
merci de répondre à nos questions vous
êtes politologue professeur à sciences
po ce n'est pas la première fois que les
américains et les russes se réunissent
autour de l'ukraine qu'est-ce qui peut
ressortir de cette énième négociations
réunion
écouter aujourd'hui on ne voit vraiment
pas ce qui peut ressortir tout
simplement parce que les russes sur sur
une position d'intransigeance absolue et
qu' ils ne veulent pas entendre parler
d'un accord quelconque d'ailleurs on ne
voit pas très bien sur le fond de quels
accords et de lesquels résultat il
pourrait s'agir parce qu'il faut appeler
rappeler que le donesk en tout cas une
grande partie de celui ci c'est à dire
les région de lougansk denain desk
species heymans ont toujours occupé de
fait par les russes et qu'aujourd'hui
une négociation qu'est ce que cela
signifierait signifierait que on
abandonnerait ses régions à l'occupant
russe je pense que c'est totalement
inacceptable et pour les ukrainiens et
pour le monde occidental
c'est d'ailleurs ce que beaucoup
craignent il pense effectivement que les
russes ont mis la pression pour que
finalement s'il n'y avait pas de guerre
cela apparaisse comme une forme de
succès pour les occidentaux ce ne serait
pas un succès parce que précisément le
crâne est toujours occupée
y at il pour autant un risque
d'incursions une nouvelle guerre est ce
qu'elle est est-ce que ce risque est
réel en ukraine oui je risque est réel
alors je dirais pas de nouvelle guerre
au pr m'en parler dans la mesure où la
guerre n'a jamais cessé il ya eu 77
morts et craignent un l'année dernière
et dernière il faut quand même le
rappeler il ya toujours cette occupation
donc la guerre en fait quand on en fait
elles existent quand on parle d'invasion
l'invasion elle a déjà existé la
question est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
une invasion une guerre de plus grande
intensité
c'est malheureusement une possibilité on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que les
américains sont faibles ne serait ce que
parce qu'ils ont accepté le principe de
ces négociations qui ne mènera nulle
part on a vu aussi joe biden céder sur
le gazoduc nord stream 2 donc tout ceci
fait un contexte où les américains et
notamment byden qui a déclaré qu'il n'y
avait plus de guerre éternelle qui était
possible du côté de l'amérique sont dans
une position de faiblesse je les
américains n'ont pas aujourd'hui c'est
aux allemands ce qui doit nous inquiéter
nous européens n'ont pas une ligne
claire par rapport au régime de poutine
alors d'un côté on a vu le secrétaire
d'état américain clint kent qui a dit
clairement s'il ya une nouvelle invasion
les russes le paieront très cher mais
d'autres un autre côté beaucoup
d'européens et les ukrainiens d'ailleurs
en premiers craignent que ces
négociations se passent finalement sans
eux ou sur leur dos ça veut dire nicolas
tenzer excusez moi mais que les russes
du coup sont en position de force ils
menacent d'appuyer sur la gâchette s'ils
n'obtiennent pas des garanties sur leur
sécurité
oui ils sont en position de force parce
que nous ne sommes pas dans une position
de force nous mêmes plus exactement nous
ne voulons pas être nous américains et
européens dans une position de force
regardez par exemple on a jusqu'à
présent refusé de fournir des armes
létales à l'ukraine on a refusé de leur
accorder en cas de conflit les moyens
d'assistance militaire notamment
surveillance aérienne renseignement etc
donc c'est ça évidemment que les russes
connaissent ils savent que il n'y a pas
de volonté suffisamment affichée du côté
des américains est d'ailleurs aussi des
européens qui sont profondément divisés
sur cette question avec d'un côté
certains qui sont sur une position de
force la plupart des pays d'europe
centrale et orientale la pologne les
états baltes et notamment et d'autres
comme l'allemagne et la france y estime
à mon avis avec beaucoup de naïveté de
dean appropriation en quelque sorte qu
une discussion une négociation est
encore possible avec ce régime merci
beaucoup nicolas tenzer politologue et
professeur à sciences po nous avoir
éclairé sur cette réunion à genève